comment allez vous les amis aujourd'hui
moi ça va très bien ça va si bien
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous
raconter des choses la dernière fois je
vous avais raconté des anecdotes sur le
jeu de mon enfance dofus et ça vous avez
carrément plus aujourd'hui je vais vous
raconter des anecdotes sur mon
adolescence
[Musique]
tout d'abord je vais vous parler d'une
chose incroyable dans l'adolescence le
pc en 2011 je faisais déjà des vidéos
sur la chaîne youtube et du cou
j'adorais a demandé les écrans je jouais
tout en jeux vidéo jeux rien et tout le
temps la télévision enfin la télévision
c'est à dire game one pass qui passait d
animer j'adorais les anime et c'est tout
le problème c'est que ma mère n'était
pas d'accord avec ça elle n'aimait pas
me voir regarder la télévision auquel me
brider elle me donnait des heures
auxquelles j'avais le droit d'accéder
aux pc et une fois leur passé je
dégageais à l'époque je vivais dans une
maison il y avait un sous sol et un
étage et le pc se trouvait au sous-sol
donc de 18 à 19 heures j'allais au
sous-sol jouer au pc et ensuite j'avais
plus le droit d'en faire ma mère voulait
pas mettre de pc dans ma chambre mais à
juste titre sinon j'aurai totalement
fait des nuits blanches et j'aurais raté
toutes mes années scolaires le ps
qu'elle savait pas c'est que le soir
quand ma mère était plongé dans un
sommeil lourd
le petit lucas sortait en cachette de sa
chambre en pyjama et qu'est ce qu'il
faisait il allait aux toilettes et
lorsqu'il tirait la chasse d'eau ils
profitaient du bruit de cette dernière
pour descendre les marches en toute
discrétion marches en bois qui font donc
un maximum de bruit donc je jouais comme
ça non plus comme ça pendant des heures
et des heures et des fois suspense
j'attendais quelqu'un descendre des
marches et là je me disais [ __ ] option
assez mon frère je m'en bats les
couilles option baisser ma mère je suis
mort dans cette pièce y avait une sorte
de placards aménagés dans lequel il y
avait la chaudière et qu'est ce que je
faisais quoi mais redescendre et je me
cachais derrière la chaudière comme une
bonne mère mais j'étais très content
parce que vu que j'étais pas dans ma
chambre je pouvais être qu'à un seul
endroit du cash de secteur
non je sais que tu es la personne tuée
est privé de pc pendant sept journaux
c'était la mission chaque soir mais ce
qui est cool c'est que j'arrivais
généralement à gratter quelques heures
de pc du coup toutes les nuits donc au
final c'était une très bonne période
parce que vous allez voir que ce qui va
suivre c'est beaucoup moins amusant
quelques années plus tard ma mère a
accepté de mettre un pc dans ma chambre
le fait est que ma mère avait aussi mis
un mot de passe on leur dit que je ne
connaissais pas
quand je voulais faire de l'anti fallait
que je lui demande et comme ma mère
adorée le chantage je me disais oui oui
oui tu as fait tes devoirs tu as rangé
sa chambre tu m'as fait un virement de
500 euros sur mon compte
ma manche pas d'argent chez que 15 alors
alors le cas une fois que j'avais fait
toutes ces tâches
j'avais enfin le droit d'aller sur
l'ordinateur ma mère venait elle taper
le mot fastes j'ai trouvé une technique
car j'étais un hacker d'exception
j'étais allé chez un pote et j'avais
graver sur un cd un truc qui permettait
de trouver le mot de passe de ton art
un jour je mets le cd dans mon pc comme
ça je lance le logiciel de hacking à
j'attends qu'ils fassent effet et il me
donne le mot de passe de mon pc guitare
ce qui est pas un mot de passe très
sécurisé du coup pendant des mois jallet
sur le pc quand je voulais sorte ma mère
le sache pas ce qu elle ne se doutait
pas que je connaissais le mot de passe
en vrai je pense qu'elle s'en doutait un
peu vu que le temps que je passais dans
ma chambre avait été multiplié par six
ans et comme j'avais pas accès à leur
dire je disais mais qu'est ce qui peut
faire dans sa chambre l'uqam et je
jouais tout le temps sans son pour être
à l'affût du moindre bruit parce que si
elle ouvrait la porte qui a brillé sur
l'ordi elle allait comprendre que je
connaissais le mot de passe me souviens
avec c'est tellement un vieux gars ok
cette année arrive la chaîne va tout
mais ça va faire du bruit et j'aurai
tort des temps des croates faire
semblant de lire un livre
rassurez vous j'ai jamais besoin d'en
arriver là gt gt gt gt moi je t'aime
alors mais pas aussi mal avec ma mère
quelques années plus tard ma mère
réfléchit à un nouveau processus lui
permettant de contrôler mon temps passé
sur les écrans lorsqu'elle a une idée de
génie engueuler son mari pour que lui il
trouve chose qu'il a fait il est
informaticien mon beau-père et [ __ ] il
a été très ingénieux un jour ma mère
vient sur leur deal flow fait tout cas
je vais retirer le mot de passe
maintenant il ya un contrôle parental ce
sera plus simple comme ça ça s'active à
telle heure ça se coupe à telle heure et
j'ai pas besoin de venir mettre de mots
de passe mais c'était pas un contrôle
parental qu'elle avait mis c'était un
contrôle de boxe mais un contrôle de
boxe au fait maison à 22h le net coupe
donc la première fois je suis surpris je
fais quoi c'est le net qui coupe le
dessin au rez-de-chaussée là où il y
avait la boxe et la mecque
je fais la découverte la plus
traumatisante de toute ma vie mon père
avait soudé un minuteur à la prise de
courant sur lequel il avait soudé
l'alimentation de la freebox
je m'étais dit [ __ ] mais mais cosef je
vais acheter une deuxième à l'hymne de
freebox et je débranche serait le cadre
de la freebox pour brancher notre alim
dessus je suis un génie c'était avant de
découvrir que le câble relié à la
freebox était cadenassée voilà c'est à
dire que mon beau-père avait soudé un
petit truc en faire et que le cadenas
bloquer le câble et que tu pouvais pas
débrancher le câble à partir de là
j'étais définitivement baiser
[Musique]
deuxième chose dont je vais vous parler
et ça c'est bizarre parce que ça
concerne je pense que ma famille c'est
la nourriture mec
moi ma mère elle avait un problème avec
les courses c'est à dire qu elle en
faisait c'était des petites courses pour
pas que ça coûte trop cher et quand on
avait tous bouffés elle attendait un
petit moment avant d'en refaire ce qui
fait qu on mourait littéralement de faim
pendant plusieurs jours du coup mon
frère et moi dans cette maison il y
avait un trésor vous voulez défendre
coûte que coûte
notre alimentation était essentiellement
constitué le matin et au goûter deux
tranches de brioche avec du nutella un
élément perturbateur le niveau du
nutella pc chaque matin mais je veux
dire chaque matin avant qu'on en prenne
dans la nuit quoi avec mon frère devenu
parano j'avais même pensé à installer
une caméra dans la cuisine pour voir qui
vous fait notre nutella dans notre dos
vous souvenez de ce que je vous ai dit
le pct au sous sol quand quelqu'un
descendez je l'entendais la nuit un jour
quelqu'un descend les escaliers je me
cache dans la chaudière comme à mon
habitude
en attendant que cette personne
remontait marché retourne dans sa
chambre mais au bout de dix minutes
toujours r je ne comprends pas je décide
alors d'aller au rez-de-chaussée voir ce
qui se passe et on ouvrant la porte de
la cuisine je découvre quelque chose qui
me traumatise à avis ma mère a croupi en
face du placard qui contenait le
précieux nutella se retourne une petite
cuillère à la main mais surtout notre
précieux pot de nutella mais elle me
regarde avec un regard bizarre en fait
elle était somnambule et régulièrement
dans son sommeil
elle allait dans la cuisine et elle
mangeait du nutella mais sans s'en
rendre compte le matin tu leur parles
elle savait pas parce qu'il était
somnambule
on avait droit impôts par semaine et
elle a mangé une partie vous pouvez rire
mais ce corps ce corps que j'ai
aujourd'hui c'est en partie à cause de
ça n'est pas plus nourrir quand il en
avait besoin
ok troisième chose dont je vous parlais
dans cette vidéo c'est les bêtises que
j'ai fait quand j'étais ado on en a tous
soient des petites bêtises or on connaît
bien alerte rouge squeeze est un gros
toy la fille d'une fois chez les flics
devinez pourquoi devinez pourquoi un
truc de toc
un truc vraiment vénèrent des flics on y
voit ça ils deviennent ou fils tu
arrêtes direct du risque d'aller en
prison et tout j'ai fait des pétards
dans un parc fermé et non je cesse
je me suis très bien les flics sont des
gens l'opération la plus ouverte de leur
carrière mon gars sont arrivés des deux
côtés du parquet il nous embarque dans
la voiture de police mais qu j'ai été
embarqué dans une voiture de police une
fois dans ma vie je suis un [ __ ] de
toc
j'arrive au commissariat ils appellent
tous nos parents ne pas envier nous
chercher ma mère arrive les flics ils
font une morale de malades
madame c'est vraiment pas bien ce qu'il
a fait oui je sais mais madame vous
rendez compte web est ok ma mère m'a
donc ramener chez moi et j'ai eu aucune
punition
elle s'en foutait un peu parce que je
faisais jamais de conneries vu que
j'étais tout le temps sur l'ordi je
pouvais pas faire de bêtises dehors
[Musique]
j'étais en troisième et j'avais ddm de
maths à faire chez moi une fois que tu
les avais fait il faut aller les scanner
et les envoyer via la messagerie du
collège à ta prof de maths au collège
j'avais donc créé un compte par élève
est ton pseudo c'était ton nom donc moi
c'est au char et ton mot de passe et à
date de naissance donc moi c'était le 27
janvier 1996 mais du coup quand
quelqu'un d'autre était née le même jour
que toi ou quand tu avais facebook
simplement tu pouvais connaître la date
de naissance de tous tes potes et te
connecter à leur compte sur la
messagerie et te faire passer pour eux
on se donne rendez vous avec tous mes
potes chez l'un d'eux qui s'appelle
quentin ok on se connecte chacun notre
messagerie on envoie tout noté m et là
moi j'ai une idée de merde et les mecs
mathilda est née même jour que moi ça
veut dire qu'on peut se connecter à son
truc
sfr fait cette toile quoi way en plus
elle est déléguée donc au [ __ ] on se
connecte au compte de 7 mathilde et on
décide d'envoyer un mail à notre prof de
maths qui n'a rien à voir avec un devoir
maison donc on a écrit un mail qui
insultait pas du tout la prof un qui dit
au contraire vous êtes vraiment belle
madame je vous ai vu à la sortie du
collège la dernière fois et mon coeur
s'est enflammé
j'aimerais un jour vous donner rendez
vous dans un restaurant pour boire un
verre tous les deux ne pourrions faire
connaissance voire même allez un petit
peu plus loin bisous sur la foufoune ce
bisou sur la foufoune c'est ça qui va
profondément nous faire du tort quatre
jours plus tard on est en cours de match
comme ça et le cpe vient chercher quand
un maire tu dix minutes plus tard le
sait peu vient et il m'appelle mois
lucas alors je le suis comme ça et il
m'amène dans le bureau du proviseur et
qu'est ce que je trouve dans le bureau
du proviseur mon pote quentin
viscéralement en train de chialer sa
grosse trace mais il n'a jamais chialer
comme ça de toute sa vie c'est sûr et il
me dit l ucao la force de ce truc je
vais te l'apprendre
il m'avait totalement balancer parce
qu'il se fait chier dessus en vrai c'est
moi qui avais eu l'idée donc d'un côté
je le comprends totalement mais moi
j'avoue que j'avais une sortie une sorte
de code d'honneur au collège c'est faux
pas balancer les potes tu as assez
morose et comme ça et ensuite le
proviseur mais disons lucas vous êtes le
cerveau de l'opération c'est comme s'il
parlait d'un braquage d'une banque
mondiale ont pas d'armes aigles un
canular dites moi qui étais avec vous ce
jour là et moi je lâche rien france dix
minutes ils essayent je lâche rien il y
avait un autre prof de maths qui étaient
là et c'est lui qui avait mis au point
qu'ils avaient co des la messagerie du
collège et là il se prends pour moi
quand j'avais le cd qui permet de
trouver le mot de passe de mon pc il
fait écouter le cas c'est très simple
vous vos 2 potes et quentin avez envoyé
vos devoirs sous la même adresse site et
vous savez ce que c'est une adresse ip
il sait tout faire transiter adresse ip
le conquet bien ça tombe à l'uqar le
mail de mathilde a été envoyé de la même
adresse ip
et là moi je suis attaché au sol je suis
pas bien dans ma tête c'est vraiment je
me dis [ __ ] non je veux pas que mes
potes tombe à cause de moi on va aller
en prison
et là j'ai une idée je dis ah mais c'est
normal en fait leur pc avait un problème
ils nous ont demandé de les envoyer pour
eux je couvre toutes sortes
d'infractions n'hésitez pas du coup
quand à et moi on s'est mangé une
semaine d'exclusion c'est hyper c'est
une sanction de ouf au collège quand
exclu une semaine c'est vraiment a fait
un truc mais de ouf
bâle a juste envoyé un mail gentil mais
j'ai fini par food et ça avait vraiment
d'un prof de maths je vous assure été
vraiment choqués je crois qu'elle a même
vu un psy derrière et où alors que mec
le mail et avait rien
quoi c'est incroyable et voilà laisser
jacques wattez vidéo je voulais trouvera
à côté tout ça parce que c'est ce qui me
reste comme souvenir de mon adolescence
il ya plein de trucs j'ai oublié la
plupart des trucs qu'ils aient oublié
mais ça je m'en souviens parce que ça va
vraiment marqué et ça m'a marqué pour
une bonne raison c'est que c'est assez
n'importe quoi finalement donc j'espère
que ça vous aura fait marrer passe un
bon moment je vous dis à bientôt deux
prochaines vidéos j'ai extrêmement soif
j'ai fait que de parler pour toutes les
vidéos
voilà j'ai la batteuse mes lèvres sont
en train de se dissoudre à léa autour
des prochaines vidéos portez vous bien
et n'oubliez pas ne fait pas de pétard
dans un parc fermé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]